hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play poisonous
all right so I got to figure out how to
get this door open shouldn't be too hard
maybe there is something in here that I
miss why I want to talk in an accent all
the time I don't know what either way I
must persevere get out of mine
oh this is all lamb okay so I went up
there I explored every room up there I
don't think I got anything that could
help me all that heart looks so good
all is good hmm I don't recall that
being anything else I could possibly
open that door like I been in each of
these rooms at oh hello and there's a
note at all house by myself
Benjamin has been in this office doing
who-knows-what
after 30 years here with Benjamin I'm
starting to really get tired of this
life yeah sounds like it
sometimes I wonder what my life could
have been ah this is Melinda the dire
this diary seems to be missing several
pages maybe I can find the warnout
extracts I can't believe what happened
today Benjamin didn't remember a wedding
anniversary
how did he forget about this day when we
married only 12 years ago only 12 years
ago lady I can't even remember what I
what I did last week okay so leg of my
back leg actually 12 years is a long
time they've been living here for 30
years and they've only been married for
I hello 412 what were they doing living
together for 18 years
shame you poor sinner huh
so I don't think I see anything else
I been in each of these rooms maybe
there was this like a switch or
something I don't know there's a lot of
books here there might be one of the
pulley books
sure I'll double-check these room then
swing back downstairs because there's
probably something down there in the
fireplace
a bellows can pick it up how suspicious
mmm
Arnel so suspicious look suspicious book
okay
don't look like there's anything away so
there must be something downstairs to
get that door open couldn't do anything
about this front door completely locked
up okay so like a secret switch behind
these curtains but yeah in HoN
absolutely or maybe the sledgehammer Oh
maybe haha
no you miss the door in tired
boo come on open up grab it yes do it
ah battering ram get out don't don't
mess with me don't mess with me
battering ram bunk bunk think bunk
pink bunk pink bunk big bunk pink
why this sledgehammer has always been
useless okay so there's obviously a key
that I need to find that I've overlooked
again must be just a tiny thing that's
just sitting somewhere very obvious that
I missed all right
oh I want to kill myself because I get
lost in the first few episodes I am that
bad I am that much suck that I always
always always always always always get
lost I get stuck I get stupider my IQ
drops if he pointed sorry I've been
drinking today and it's just no
that's getting to me I haven't been I
really don't drink much other than my
drunk minecraft series maybe it's one of
these paintings that one was removable
in holy hell there might be others that
are who knows it could be it's entirely
possible
it's almost plausible I don't think I
double-checked this room actually I
crashed all these open but I didn't look
at him
no all right no never mind
what oh hey
not all the candlesticks on the wall are
the same in the library ah
Oh interesting that's actually cool
because it like I don't know if that was
a timer thing like I haven't made
progress in a while but not all the
candlesticks in the library is this the
library or is the other one the library
yeah if it yeah must have been a time
thing ah ah that should have been
obvious what junk oh hello oh gosh shut
up yes alright anyway oh wow that's nice
that's nice it's a nice touch because it
keeps people like me from being lost
because I was very obscure I I never
would have guessed I've never had to
look and stuff like that before so I
wouldn't have thought to look at I
probably would have found it eventually
like I wait a minute that looks a little
different but would take me well I see
you back there gathering Bible getting
plenty of tinder box oh that's always a
good sign I like having many of those I
always leave my Let's Plays of these
custom stories on a surplus ah finally
some sensible climbing what the hell
ah what uh you fell what a douche
their hand just slap you and you felt
like a little girl like a teachers girl
little I'll get up I don't need a waster
thing just yet I don't think there we go
I'll recover I just need to get to the
light get in there
there we go get in there huh okay I got
the key it's either to this door or what
what that okay all right it's not to
that one it must be to the door
downstairs such because rachel is in
there probably being murdered to death
if any of my lady fans got trapped and
abducted by a monster I'd be there in
days flats rescue you you know me I'm a
chivalrous as they come right ladies
right yeah I know
oh pretty I like it very large and in
charge stapling now this is actually a
well designed looking on chairs good my
friend
it's a well-designed looking mansion
this is the first mansion I've been in
that actually looks like a mate
maybe I could find something to place on
this pressure-sensitive
pressure-sensitive pad so that the key
cabinet stays open
how about hmm is even a light on I like
this I like this mod maker he's doing
very very interesting things a pressured
wait I didn't even think that like
feasible with the tools available ah
okay so I need to find something heavier
than a chair two chairs I don't know how
about I logically insert them this way
chart you son of a [ __ ] I will destroy
you and everything you hold dear sorry I
didn't mean that chair I meant it
damn yo nope nope chair 69 does not work
well I've got more chairs where that
came from I have got all these chairs so
many chairs
oh what about the sledgehammer no I'm a
stupid idiot a sledgehammer that was
right over here who's over here right
yeah yeah yeah yeah it seems heavy it's
very like hard to carry although I can
throw it like a mile cuz I'm just so
strong wrong yeah right lady yeah okay
enough of that moving on moving on ha ha
ha
come on oh so slow ah no how about you
go screw yourself ya know what do I put
on there
what is that shield I don't know see
anything in here oh man well if that
doesn't work then what the hell don't I
gonna use this should be like some
barrel or something a dead body
sounds about right that's about the same
weight as I am hey look it's a dead body
perfect just what I needed I'm gonna
laugh if this actually works I will I
will laughs oh let's see let's stuff
that on there get the sledgehammer nice
and in there nope nope did not work gah
what do I need I swear this is
ridiculous
all right so let's just go in the other
rooms I obviously don't need a juice yet
so oh yeah that's some strong ass wind
nice fog - OH
all right ah ah three to myself what god
no oh diary oh I haven't seen people use
a diary in a while
today the local bakery delivered the
cake for Benjamin's birthday we will
celebrate later this evening
he's turning 57 this year but on the
cake it's at 56 how could they do wrong
when I specifically told them that he
was born in from 1945 I sure won't give
them any tip oh okay ah there goes all
the sex appeal I just had with my female
viewers just right there all gone and
out the window what what the hell what
oh I guess that's intelligent use of
game resources not having the backs of
things that aren't usually seen as good
way of eliminating unnecessary polygons
okay all right what the hell do I need
to put on this thing
dear sigh what the hell grandfather
clock on entire couch my god I don't
know I've got like serious I'm stacking
up everything on top this stupid
pressure plate is now working cat get
out there maybe you write on there to be
straight up no don't mess with me again
don't mess with me don't don't
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh I know good no no we're
not doing this dance there we go stand
straight up nope nice headstand tours oh
there's a what do i there's nothing out
here that could be used possibly to do
this this is an impossible task this
task is very difficult
haha I can't jump out the window again
well now these unorthodox puzzles are
rather intriguing what about this metal
chair why is there a hand on this
template oh no someone's a cannibal
someone eats your fish
alright I guess I'll just go
maybe I'll just stack more and more and
more but I don't know why something
isn't equivalent why all of this stuff
that I've already assembled is an
equivalent to a person if I stand on it
it opens in a closing opens and it
closed and it opens and closes maybe the
logic is like with the torso thing maybe
I got to get all the body parts in here
I heard something like right behind me
and weird yeah maybe because you know
maybe I was right on the track you know
right on there with you know hey maybe a
dead body maybe I was right on there and
I just didn't follow through with it
where'd that go where did I throw that
other leg oh my god if I lost the other
leg I swear I'm gonna be so good there
it is thank you Oh can't keep you can't
keep losing my limbs like this all right
so there's one hand playing hopscotch
with them there's my one leg and as your
leg okay oh god if this works I swear
this is like unorthodox to the max what
I like the way this guy thinks kind of
maybe hand other hand nope not yet but
I've got legs splat oh come on go
through the freaking thing leg leg of
man or woman I reckon I think leg of man
cuz that torso looked like a man torso
dunk no art smithing a head isn't it God
wanted to work why not work II uh-oh
maybe I could find something to place on
these pressure-sensitive better okay re
if that doesn't work there are barrels
in the other room I know get those I
suppose
hey I'm sorry I'm getting stuck on the
most simple puzzles but it's like I know
the answer I just this is hard to
execute it correctly because I don't
know what exactly it wants if anything
if anything I would assume that these
barrels if I stack both of them on top
of each other and then the sledgehammer
up top maybe that would work maybe just
maybe well I don't know though oh I
don't know boink boink
once again I'm so super strong that
could just chuck them through the air
what makes sense because barrels are
easy to stack up there yeah that was a
terrible idea of putting a dead body on
there ones I think rooted here we go
and boink that's one yeah oh come on oh
come on sledgehammer on top bed amber on
top ah
not if room yeah nope ah [ __ ] your
barrels oh okay alright well that's
stupid
this is stupid still bad okay God so do
it I'm out of time ah
if you guys know what I'm supposed to do
please call me an idiot call me an idiot
down there shake you're a big idiot also
wait is an idiot just cuz you know like
if you're calling anyone away you got a
call waiting idiot to call so I'm an
idiot
Wade's an idiot if you know the answer
write in the comments below I'm an idiot
Wade's an idiot so thank you all so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the box
in the next part bye bye